Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain an episode from
the American anthology series: Creepshow called
Skincrawlers.
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the episode, an advertisement
for a clinic called Skin Deep by Sloane is
shown which is promoting something miraculous.
According to this advert, man has been obsessed
with his image since the beginning of time
but now with this new ‘body sculpting’
technique by Skin Deep, they can perfect this
image and look flawless.
The advert continues by mentioning that one
doesn't even have to exercise to gain results
as the procedure is instant.
Next, the advert shows before and after images
of a girl named Debbie who looked extremely
obese before the procedure, but 3 days later,
looked slim and perfect.
Debbie, who has now become the ambassador
of the clinic, mentions that Skin Deep by
Sloane helped her change her life and now
she is ready to help others.
The advert then continues with an animated
video showing how the procedure is conducted.
Apparently a leech like creature will suck
on the fat of the obese people, making them
slim and good looking instantly.
The procedure is also 100 percent painless
and safe.
The advert ends as the driving force behind
the project; Dr. Herber Sloan introduces himself
and promises everyone that they will get the
body they deserve.
Henry, a middle aged fat guy is seen watching
the Skin Deep advertisement on the television
when he is approached by Debbie.
Debbie thanks him for being a regular customer
of Dr. Sloan's previous products and places
him with other clients, who are also waiting
for the procedure.
She then informs the group that the doctor
will be there soon.
Sitting next to him is a girl named Kelly
who is trying to hide her face with a newspaper.
Henry introduces himself but she is a bit
nervous because of her extremely obese looks.
She informs Henry that she doesn’t care
about anything but reducing her weight so
that she can look like Debby.
Later, Dr. Sloane arrives and starts explaining
to them how the whole procedure will be conducted.
He mentions that the patient will feel no
pain and within just 3 days, he/she will be
able to get the body of their dreams.
At this time, the ambassador, Debbie, brings
a whole tray of donuts in front of the customers.
Dr. Sloane encourages everyone to take a bite
and assures that after they perform the procedure,
they will be able to eat donuts without hesitation
and also maintain their body without exercise.
Despite the assurance, everyone refuses the
offer other than Henry, who takes one.
After the small introduction, Dr. Sloane gives
the same ‘man has been obsessed with his
image since ages’ BS and informs that while
there is no fountain of youth, there is a
way to look perfect.
He then reveals the creatures which are supposed
to suck all the fat from the patient’s body
to make them good looking.
The creatures have suckers on them and look
like something out of an alien movie.
Henry is frightened to witness the creatures
and immediately asks about them.
Dr. Sloane then starts giving some backstory
on how he found them.
He and his team were in the South American
rainforest looking for fat-melting berries
when they came across these creatures.
Since 2012, they have only managed to collect
10 of these, making them incredibly rare.
As for the procedure, these enhanced form
of leeches secrete a fluid which completely
numbs the patient's skin and extracts all
the fat harmlessly.
The doctor also assures that this procedure
has been tested several times and all the
other organs of the body are left unharmed.
As soon as the doctor finishes explaining
the procedure, Kelly takes out money from
her purse and expresses her desire to get
registered.
She does not seem to care whether it is all
true or not as she is blinded by her dream
of becoming slim and beautiful.
Many customers behind Kelly also show interest
and they leave with Debbie to get registered.
Only Henry remains who is still frightened
by the creatures.
Dr. Sloan then explains to him that he too
got through the procedure and now is living
a very normal and happy life.
He adds that he got the muscular physique
with the help of the fat sucking leech.
He suggests Henry to take the advantage of
the opportunity and get a perfect body he
always has wished for.
Dr. Sloan further adds that the company has
done experiments in large quantities before,
which has resulted in no harm to humans.
Despite the persuasion from the doctor, Henry
still sees the creatures as disgusting and
decides he will never let them get into his
body.
He then takes a bite out of the donut and
leaves the clinic.
Two weeks later, Henry is at a park eating
junk food when he notices that the people
he met in the clinic have lost their weights.
They all are looking great with their appealing
physique.
He observes that some have found the love
of their lives while some are flaunting their
muscles.
Seeing all this, he gets jealous and annoyed.
As he is regretting his decision from two
weeks earlier, Kelly comes across and sits
next to him.
Just like the others, Kelly looks stunning
and Henry is taken aback to see her in such
an amazing physique.
The girl who looked like a ball two weeks
ago, is now a very beautiful and appealing
woman.
Henry finds it difficult to believe his eyes.
Kelly tells Henry that she is now a representative
model of the weight loss company.
She also mentions that the company is now
recruiting volunteers to test the effect of
weight loss.
She then invites him to be one of the volunteers
in the AM America show, which will be broadcasted
live.
After Kelly leaves, a confused Henry takes
a big bite of the bread he is holding.
Henry tried many different ways to lose his
weight, but in the end he failed as he could
not stop his mouth.
He ultimately decides to be one of the volunteers
as Kelly suggested and tries to trust every
step in the process.
In the next scene, we see Henry approaching
the television program where they are about
to display the procedure live in front of
the audience.
Henry is chosen as the volunteer on which
the experiment will be performed.
The company wants to use this marketing technique
to improve its reputation.
At the same time, the two reporters on set
reveal that it is solar eclipse day.
They then ask field reporter Jim Scott to
describe the event.
Jim says that while the eclipse will last
for just 160 seconds, it will be seen across
the entire United States, something which
hasn’t happened in over a century.
When asked if the eclipse can cause any problems,
Jim reveals that it won't affect the humans,
but the pets can have slight behavioral changes
due to the change in magnetic fields caused
by the eclipse.
However, everyone takes the suggestion lightly
and the show introduces Dr. Sloane.
The doctor promises everyone that they will
be amazed and the show goes into an interval.
Henry feels a little nervous about performing
the procedure on himself.
However, he is also optimistic as he dreams
about finding the love of his life.
We also see Kelly motivating him and making
him feel comfortable.
The show begins, and everyone takes their
places on the stage, waiting for the fat sucking
leech to be revealed.
Dr. Sloane seems a bit uneasy at this point,
but pays little attention.
He then removes the cover, revealing the fat-eating
creature to everyone.
The show's female host approaches it with
confidence and gets a closer look at the creature.
Henry examines the bug as well, and he begins
to have second thoughts about the procedure.
My man Henry is as unsure as a kid on Christmas.
Just then, the eclipse takes place and it
causes the creature to wiggle continually.
It starts twisting its body in an unusual
way.
At this point, Keely starts feeling a bit
uneasy and asks Henry if there is something
in her eye.
The field reporter Jim Scott is also struggling
as his stomach is continuously making rumbling
noises as if something is trying to come out.
When the moon completely covers the sun, a
similar leech-like creature pops out of Kelly’s
eyes and at the same time, Jim’s head explodes
and something comes out.
In the studio, the people start to panic and
scream.
With the leeches peeping out of Kelly’s
eyes, she also falls to the ground.
Frightened, the rest of the staff start running
out of the studio.
Unfortunately, some of them are also found
to have undergone the fat losing procedure
and have the parasites in them.
Just like Kelly and Jim, they also succumb
to the monsters.
All the leeches start to break through the
human bodies that have undergone the procedure.
Dr. Sloane quickly tries to escape from the
studio but is caught by Henry and is held
against the wall.
Henry then accuses Sloane of knowing everything
but still going through it just for the sake
of money.
However, Dr. Sloane pleads that he didn’t
know something like this was going to unfold.
In a remorseful tone, he expresses that he
conducted research on all the possibilities
except one; when a solar eclipse occurs.
As he is pleading his innocence, Dr. Sloane
also starts feeling uneasy and he drops to
the ground unconscious.
When Henry tries to approach him to check
if he is faking, the doctor’s body explodes
and Henry’s face is splattered with blood.
A giant alien-like creature with sharp teeth
and tentacles then emerges out of the body
and starts grabbing Henry by the legs.
A tussle ensues which ends in Henry crushing
the creature with the nearby vending machine.
After flexing his victory, Henry grabs a chocolate
bar from the floor covered in blood and starts
having a bite of it.
Henry will never change.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.